[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACK VARGAS: Hey, everyone.
Good afternoon.
Thank you for joining
us during your lunch,
or hopefully you're
skipping your lunch
to check us out here.
First time I've presented
in a movie theater.
Too bad we're not doing,
like, "Avengers End Game."
That would be a
pretty cool session.
But we're here to actually
talk about a partnership
between SAP, Google,
and Intel, specifically
around a technology called Intel
Optane DC Persistent Memory.
I'm Jack Vargas.
I'm one of the product
managers at Intel
working on this technology.
Soon, in the next
couple of sessions,
I'll be joined by my friends,
Tim, Andreas, and Rohit.
So to give you an overview
about why we're here
and what we're
talking about, I'll
spend the first
section talking a bit
about the history
of this journey,
what this technology is about,
and why we're even doing it.
Then Tim will come up,
talk about SAP HANA,
and then Andreas and Rohit will
join us for the final session.
We plan to have a
couple of minutes
for Q&A. I know
it's kind of dark,
but there are some mics
up here on this second row
here, so if you have any
questions, just head on down
and we'll take your questions
toward the end of it.
All right.
So first, I want to
talk about this journey
that Intel's been on.
We've been working on this
technology for the past 10
years.
And really, the last six of that
has been in deep engineering
collaboration with
SAP, specifically
optimizing SAP HANA
to take advantage
of this new technology category
called persistent memory.
And the last couple
of years have
been really exciting for
the partners listed up here.
So actually, two years ago,
SAP was the very first company
to demo persistent memory
live at SAP Sapphire.
And then this past fall,
during an Intel event,
we gave Bart Sano, who is a
VP at Google Cloud, the very
first production DIMM of this
Intel Optane DC Persistent
Memory, and that kind of
started a slew of activities
working with SAP.
Google Partners to really
start prototyping and doing
POCs around this technology.
And then actually
just a week ago,
Intel officially launched this
Intel Optane DC Persistent
Memory general
availability, along
with our second generation of
Intel Xeon Scalable Processor.
Now why is Intel-- why are
these companies kind of rallying
behind this technology?
What's the big deal?
What's going on?
And it really has
to do with data.
So in the short now
six years, in 2025,
we're expected to generate
175 zetabytes of data
compared to 33 zetabytes
generated in the last year.
You know, current technologies
aren't really equipped
to make that data useful to
the industries, your customers,
your partners.
So let's explore
kind of why that
is to give you a
fundamental knowledge of why
this technology is
going to change computer
architecture as we know it.
So here's kind of
the classical pyramid
diagram of current
technologies when
it comes to memory and storage.
Now you may notice there
are big gaps between these,
and in the realm of
computer architectures,
these are oceans away.
So at the very top, we have
memory, which currently
the mainstay is DRAM memory.
So this is tiny capacities
compared to what you
can see in solid state devices.
It can be relatively expensive
but it's really fast.
We actually measure latency in
nanoseconds within this realm.
Now we cross the gap and
we enter the storage realm,
which currently the two
main technologies are
flash NAND SSDs and then as
well as spinning magnetic disks,
like hard drives, or even tape.
Typically, latency
measured in these
are within the realm
of microseconds.
So again, a magnitude different
than what we have with memory.
Though in the storage realm,
they have higher capacities,
they're fairly affordable
for the gigabyte per cost,
but again, they're a magnitude
different in performance.
So this bottleneck has actually
been in computer architecture
for quite some time, where
actually software has really
just worked around this
by really optimizing code
to make an advantage of it.
Now how we're
changing this equation
is by this new technology called
Intel Optane DC Persistent
Memory--
really the first mainstream
persistent memory technology
that's coming to
the marketplace.
So this is big, affordable,
as well as the data on it
can be persistent even after a
server reboot, a power loss, et
cetera.
We're coming to
market with the 128,
256, and 512, and
actually in my pocket,
I have one of our 512
capacities right here.
So with these, you can
have a total of six
of these on a second generation
Xeon processor platform
and you pair those with a DRAM.
So on one socket, six of these.
On a standard two-socket
server, you can have up to 12.
So if you take the 512,
multiply that by 12,
you have a total of six
terabytes of persistent memory
available on your platform.
Now also, I will mention that
since now in the memory realm,
data's at rest, security
is quite important.
So these actually come in with
standard hardware encryption.
All right, now I'm going to give
just a quick download of how we
actually use this technology.
So there are specifically
two operating modes.
So think of one as
being persistent memory,
and I'll get into details
of how you can use that,
and the other one is
actually kind of our easy way
to take advantage of that
large memory footprint
but without the persistency,
and we call that memory mode.
So let me talk about
app direct mode.
So in app direct
mode, this technology
is transparent to your
operating system, your users,
your application,
and smart ISVs--
Independent Software
Vendors-- like SAP,
who understand their data
structures very well,
will put the data
structures which
make the most
sense in the medium
that they have available.
So for those data
structures that
make the most
sense in DRAM where
you need that high bandwidth,
they can put the data structure
there, but if you
could utilize maybe
a lot of persistent
memory and take advantage
of it being persistent
if I had to do a server
patch or something, it's
able to come up quickly
versus previous generations.
I will make note, with app
direct, there is that usage
but there is actually a second
usage where you can actually
use standard storage APIs.
So instead, if you wanted to
just use standard block IO
or actually boot from the DIMMs
itself, we do support that.
Now with memory mode,
how this is utilized
is basically the
platform is going
to consume the
DRAM in your system
to act as a really
fast write-back cache.
So from an application
standpoint,
that six terabytes I mentioned
before, we'll just see that six
terabyte and won't see the DRAM
behind that acting as a cache.
So with, this, again
this is a volatile usage,
and really this is to be
out-of-the-box if you want
to have six terabytes
available of volatile memory.
This is the route to go.
Now hopefully that's a quick 101
of Intel Optane DC Persistent
Memory.
I'll turn it over to my friend
Tim now to talk about SAP HANA.
TIM ALLEN: So I'm Tim Allen.
I'm on the SAP account team.
So SAP is the first
major RDBMS to support
Intel Optane Persistent
Memory in app direct mode.
Now today it's kind of fitting.
My name is Tim Allen, I
used to do a little acting,
we're in a movie theater.
So I just wanted to--
just made me think
about my prior life.
So when we think of Intel
Optane DC Persistent Memory,
this kind of fills in the blanks
that Jack was talking about.
As you can see, there's this
new layer, persistent memory,
that kind of bridges the gap
between storage and memory.
And like I said, SAP,
we've been working on it
for several years.
It finally launched last week.
So when you look at Intel
Optane DC Persistent Memory,
I look at HANA 2.3.
HANA 2.3 was released prior
to Sapphire last year.
It was the first major database
to support persistent memory.
And now we have some specifics.
Now Andreas, I'm not
going to talk about 2.4,
but obviously we know that's
imminently coming soon, but OK.
So it's imminent.
It was released last Friday.
So this one could be updated
but it's still the same--
as I like to think of it, SAP
has supported persistent memory
for a long time, even
before the product released.
OK?
Now a couple of things
to pull off this foil
is, with persistent
memory, and this is just
compared to last generation or
the first generation of Intel
Xeon Platinum processor.
For transactions, this supports
up to 3x more capacity,
and for analytics,
it supports up to 6x.
So I'll get into specifics
of how that works there.
Now, historically,
at Intel, we've
worked with SAP for
over a decade on HANA.
Each generation, we've
added either new features
of the Xeon processor level.
As an example, about
three or four years ago,
we added a feature
called TSX which sped up
by transactions by almost 500%.
And that was the E7V3 platform.
And fast forward this year, we
released the second generation
of the Intel Xeon
Platinum processor
and now we support persistent
memory at the processor level.
And so this kind of gives
you a brief summary.
Now I know there's not a
one-to-one mapping with GCP,
but at least it tells you at the
processor level, historically,
for transactions, what
were some limitations.
So if we look back
to the E7V4, we
supported up to three
terabytes per processor.
With the last generation
of the processor,
we sped up everything
by about 60%
if you look at some of the
SAP B W for HANA benchmarks.
However, we took half
of the processor--
or I should say, we took
half of the DIMM slots away.
So that's why you see it went
down from three terabytes
to 1.5.
Well, at this level you
still have the same amount
of DIMM slots as you did as
the first generation of Intel's
Xeon platinunm processor.
But now we support up to
4.5 terabytes per processor.
And if you think about that,
that's pretty powerful.
So what does that say?
On a four-socket
configuration you
can actually have 18 terabytes.
So when I think of data
management challenges,
obviously we know our
data always grows.
There's always a consistent
cost of how do we manage it?
What's our operational budget?
And then how can we get answers
and solve problems quicker
for our customers?
So decrease time to value.
When I think of
persistent memory,
I think it solves kind
of this heat map issue.
So traditionally-- and Jack
referred to this previously--
you just had three tiers.
You had your DRAM
for your in-memory.
And then for things--
now I have to admit, in
another previous life
I used to be a DBA.
And even within memory
you don't store everything
in the in-memory database.
So like your data that's your
quarterly or monthly reports,
you likely will put
that in warm data, which
is the orange represented here.
And the blue data is
for your big data stuff
that you'd store in cloudera
or something similar.
Now with persistent memory
and this larger capacity
what you see is kind of
a emerging or a new zone,
the second to the left there.
The Intel Optane DC
Persistent Memory zone,
which has both the capacity to
store warm and and hot data.
Now when I think
about this, what do I
I think about at
a database layer?
Specifically the main memory,
or about 95% of your data,
can now be stored in
persistent memory.
This also applies to
potential new features
that were added in HANA
2.3, like extension nodes.
So that gives you an opportunity
to put persistent memory
both in the hot and
the warm data tiers.
Now what I also think
about persistent memory,
it's we are driving the cost
down of compute on HANA.
When I think of historical
on-premise scenario,
I'm hearing customers just last
year were buying new systems.
And they're telling
me that about 60%
of the cost of that system
was just the memory card.
So we're going to drive
down that cost with the dems
that we just released.
And there's going to be better
opportunities for business
continuity.
And this is a good place
where GCP plays it.
I'm hearing some
customers that kind of
have a hybrid scenario where
they will still host locally
on their data
center, but they're
going to use replication
to do disaster
recovery, for instance,
to the Google Cloud.
So that's something to think
about in your scenario.
And I already talked a little
bit about increased memory
capacity.
OK.
So when we delve a
little deeper we're
also seeing with this increased
capacity an opportunity not
just from a lower dem
price perspective or price
per gigabyte.
There's opportunities to
consolidate multiple instances.
Intel IT in particular
were actually
in the process of consolidating
both our ECC and another HANA
native instance into one.
So look for solutions
where you're
discussing that in detail here
in the next couple of weeks
leading up to Sapphire.
The other thing I
like to think about,
and I alluded to this earlier,
I call this the layer cake.
But as you can see,
this is a piece of cake
that's fallen on its side.
And now we have
the area in green
is where persistent
memory falls into place.
That is your main data stores.
Now as Jack said to
previously, you're
still going to need some
DRAM, but the vast majority
of the HANA database in orange
is where your main memory
is going to be stored.
So it's going to
vary per customer,
but rough estimates I'm
hearing is between 95%,
96% of your data will now
be in persistent memory.
And that's going to
improve your loading,
reloading of the
database at startup.
It's going to improve the
time, the data load of that,
significantly.
It's going to go from
potentially up to an hour
to minutes.
The last thing I want to talk
about is business continuity.
Now, there's lots
of things when you
think of business continuity.
The first thing I think of,
first and foremost, is backup.
As you can see, this
actually shows an opportunity
to introduce persistent memory
into your existing environment,
where you still have some
older systems that just have
all DRAM, and now you can
do a replication scenario
where you can use
persistent memory
on the right with the orange--
the darker orange-- with
some DRAM because you now
have a bigger footprint.
This can also be
used for backup.
This can be used for
disaster recovery
at a different location.
It could be used on the
Google Cloud, as an example.
And the last one is a new use
case with extension nodes.
So extension nodes
was a new feature
that was added in HANA 2.3.
It does not replace
dynamic tiering.
That still exists.
But it's a feature that allows
you to place your warm data
into persistent
memory, and then has
the scaling factor of 8 to 1.
In other words, you can
have eight times as much
persistent memory in the dark
orange as you have with DRAM.
So look to SAP to
get more details
on how to implement that.
The other thing nice
with extension nodes
is it gives you a full HANA
instance for your warm data,
and then that will give you full
access to all the PAL libraries
to do analytics.
With that, I'll turn
it over to Andreas.
ANDREAS SCHUSTER:
Thanks a lot, Tim.
So microphone is working.
My name is Andreas Schuster.
I flew here all the way
from [INAUDIBLE],, Germany,
so I'm representing SAP in
this long-standing cooperation
between the three companies.
I'm the product manager for
persistent memory in SAP HANA.
And before I get started and
telling us a little bit more
about how HANA is actually using
it and what it means for HANA,
let's briefly wrap up
what we just heard.
So we had Jack in the
very beginning introducing
the technology itself of Intel
Optane DC persistent memory,
this new, pretty nice, pretty
exciting hardware technology.
And we had Tim
speaking about SAP HANA
and a couple of use
cases that we see
how HANA can make use of that.
But what does that
actually mean for SAP HANA
and for SAP HANA on GCP?
So this is a pretty
packed slide.
I have to admit that.
But it actually gives a pretty
good outline of the use cases
that we see and the benefits.
So basically, the
main benefit being,
you can actually
process more data
in real time, so at basically
the same performance
as if it was in DRAM.
The TCO is supposed to be
much, much more, well, better
for you and for
companies, or it's
cheaper than traditional DRAM.
And one aspect that we
haven't really touched so far
is the improved
business continuity.
So the main differences between
persistent memory and DRAM
is not just size and
cost, but it's also
that it is persistent.
So it means that it doesn't
lose the data when you shut down
the server or the database,
which is something
that, well, at some
point, you just have to do
if you need to do maintenance.
So for applying a database
upgrade, or an operating system
upgrade, or just to--
yeah.
And so you can
actually imagine what
it means for running a
memory database like HANA.
So all the data is kept in
main memory at all times
to be able to process
it and to process it
with the speed and a performance
that you actually expect
and that HANA is promising.
But it also means that if
you shut down the database,
all the DRAM and data gets
de-allocated, giving it back
to the operating system.
And when the database
is coming back up,
the database SAP HANA
needs to reload that
from a persistent layer, which
is the case of SAP HANA's
just simple storage.
Now SAP's offering
or positioning
HANA in big data environments,
so for large amounts
of data into terabytes scale.
And if you imagine, so no matter
how fast the storage actually
is, it takes some time.
So if you need to load six
terabytes of data from an SSD,
even if it's a very fast
SSD, into main memory,
this can take a
considerable amount of time.
So what we were able
to achieve in this area
is an improvement
by a factor of 12.5.
So it is based on
the lab example
that we did before
Sapphire last year.
So we were able to reduce
the startup time, including
the data-loading phase from
15 minutes to just 4 minutes.
So this means your
database is basically
going to be back much faster
after a maintenance phase
than it was before.
And, of course, SAP
is also very proud
on the long-standing
collaboration
so that we actually
are able to announce
that we are the first major
database that is fully
supporting that.
We touched briefly
the two operating
modes of persistent
memory before,
so memory mode and app direct.
Memory mode is basically the--
you can run every
application in memory mode.
But to actually take full
advantage of the technology,
including the
persistency aspects,
that takes the app direct mode.
And this is also--
so we spent significant efforts
in our engineering department
to actually enable SAP
HANA for that technology.
And we got great assistance
from Intel in that, by the way.
So basically, summarizing
that again, so you get
reduced TCO and four
times increase in density,
so from under 28
to 512 gigabyte.
These are the ones that
are available right now.
And you can also, you
have to put a potential
to simplify your landscape.
So we have seen a
couple of examples
before, so because you can
make use of that capacity
to put in more data, or just
install two databases on one
physical server or one server in
general, so it can, of course,
also be virtualized.
This, in some cases, allows
you to actually avoid
a scale-out scenario,
so a scenario
where you logically
combine two servers to one.
I mean, it's
basically two servers.
So you also, in terms
of operating that,
it becomes more
complex, which is also
pretty good value proposition
is the aspect of data tiering.
So persistent memory is not per
se a data-tiering technology.
So that's not how
it is positioned,
and it also would not
be fair to call it
that because the performance
is actually not for warm data,
so you don't have any
performance difference
if you keep data there.
But it certainly
has an influence
on how you do data
tiering or whether you
have to do data tiering
in the first place.
Because let's assume you have
50% of your database size
is warm data, data
that you could actually
move somewhere else, by
using just DIMMS that
are twice as large, you can
just keep that in your hot tier.
You have the same
performance for the hot data,
and what I think is
even more important,
you don't need to go through
that whole project of actually
identifying what
data is warm and you
don't need to move the data.
You can just leave it as it is.
It is simpler from an
operations perspective.
And you yeah, also,
basically, you
don't need to add
an additional system
like dynamic tiering or another
external code data tier.
Yeah.
I explained about the business
continuity aspect already,
so it is 12.5 times improvement
in restart times or data
loading times at startup.
This lab example, we have
actually proved that many times
during the last year.
So we've done a couple of POCs
with customers, so real life
customer systems,
and sometimes we've
even seen much higher
factors, so up to factor 21.
Depends a little bit on the
actual size of the database.
So because the
larger your system
is, the more time
you save basically
by not having to load
that data and the higher,
also, the factor becomes.
So on Google Cloud.
So Google Cloud has also been
a very collaborative partner
for Intel and SAP
in the last year.
And today, Google Cloud is
actually the first public cloud
provider to offer
virtual machines that
use persistent memory.
So the instances that GCP
is offering, it's a 96 vCPU,
7 terabyte virtual machine,
so 7 terabyte combined
DRAM and persistent memory, of
which 80% is actually obtained,
so persistent memory
a factor of 1 to 4.
This basically brings you
a higher overall capacity
at a lower cost or at the
same cost as a smaller one.
Then you should
just compare that
to a system with just DRAM.
OK.
So to put a couple more
numbers behind that promise
that we make in terms
of restart time,
and to also show you
how it actually works,
or how HANA is designed and what
the startup time is actually
composed of, so there
are two components
that are pretty stable.
It's like the HANA
shutdown and HANA startup.
This is just to basically
load the binaries
and to shut down the software.
So this stays
pretty much the same
no matter what
data size you have
and also whether you use
DRAM or persistent memory.
So there's not too much that
you can actually improve there.
But what is really,
really important
is the time that it takes you
until your database is back
for normal operations,
so the time
until you can use your
database in the same way
and with the same performance as
you could before you shut down
the database.
And this is-- yeah.
Here these bars on
the very right one,
so with persistent
memory, in this case,
it took 23 seconds
compared to 280,
which roughly corresponds
to that factor
that we've seen before.
And this difference
will, of course,
increase the larger
your systems get.
So if you have--
I mean, HANA is
available in sizes up
to 24 terabytes for
a single instance,
so you can expect even larger
improvements if you're actually
running a system in that size.
So this slide is actually
very similar from what
it tries to tell.
So how did downtime of a typical
SAP system actually looks like?
So there is typically a phase
where you prepare your downtime
in the very beginning, so
you prepare the application
to actually make it ready and
to tell the [INAUDIBLE] database
I'm going to be shut down.
It takes a couple of minutes,
so that's actually not too long.
And then there's, in
this slide, there's
a pretty large
downtime of 45 minutes.
So this is actually
the maintenance task
that you need to execute
on your database.
The duration of data,
of course, varies.
So 45 minutes is already
a pretty large one,
so like an operating system
upgrade or a HANA database
upgrade.
It's also a time that
you cannot really avoid,
so this is just what
it takes to get ready.
And then the interesting part
is when you start to host again.
So you see on the upper
one, the upper bar,
shows persistent
memory obtained,
where after just four
minutes after you instantiate
or basically
re-instantiate a database,
it is back with the same
performance as it was before.
If you compare that to how it
looks with DRAM, in this case,
so the data, when it's loaded,
it's, of course, prioritized,
so the most important
data is loaded first
so that the system can come
back as fast as possible.
So 34 minutes it takes in
this case to get to 2 and 1/2
terabyte ready with the
most important tables
so that your system
can go back to--
actually [INAUDIBLE].
But the time it takes
for the full 5 terabyte
is even longer so, in
this case, almost an hour.
So you can imagine what that
actually means for your system.
And with this, I'd
like to hand over
to Rohit who will tell a little
bit more about the roadmap.
ROHIT KAMATH:
Thank you, Andreas.
So here, just to give you guys
a quick overview of Google's
journey on providing
system sizes,
Google has been true to
providing all the systems
as virtual machines so far.
So you'll see on
the roadmap, when
we started off back in 2017
was the first HANA system that
was 208-gig or memory.
And we have come a long way.
Now, if you look
at Q4 2018, we're
able to release up to a
4-terabyte single node
machine that's available.
And now, with the partnership
from SAP and Intel and Google,
now we're able to release the
first 7-terabyte system that's
running on Optane memory.
And further down
the road map, you'll
see a couple of
months down the road,
we will be releasing the
6-terabyte and the 12-terabyte,
again, single node
virtual machines
that will be available to
run HANA as single node scale
up mode.
And then around the
end of the year,
we will be releasing the
18-terabyte VM again.
So to conclude today,
thanks to Intel and SAP
to introduce you folks
to the Intel Optane DC
persistent memory-based
HANA systems that will
be available in Google Cloud.
We have information available,
further information.
You can always contact
Tim, Andreas, and Zach
for further questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]